all right now another thing that we were
saying and we didn't really explain it
but we said yeah you could just do it
is when there's a number at the front
right you know how we could deal with X
to the 4 what's the derivative of X to
the 4 for X to the power of 3 so you
just like coefficient comes out the
front power reduces okay and then we
said to you for something like this
you're like I just forget about that 3
for a minute right what happens to the x
squared 2 comes out the front 2 becomes
a 1 so it's that's just 2x and then we
said I'll now put it back right now
how can we just say that well I'm going
to go back to first principles right if
instead of a sum of functions what if I
had multiples of a function right what
if I had had that right sum function
which was just another function
multiplied by a constant right so let's
call that other function G and let's
call out our constant number at the
front it can doesn't have to be 3 or 8
or negative 2 let's just call it a where
a is any number you like okay think
about how this will work with first
principles when you go ahead and you say
f - okay what's the first thing I'm
going to write in my first principles
it's always the first thing it's written
up there the limit write the limit I'm
interested in these tangents not
sequence okay now I want to do this next
part right think about this carefully
instead of writing this i'm gonna reply
replace it with this function j plus you
multiply by a constant right so the
first thing will be a times what what's
going to be in here have a look we
always start with the higher-value
rights as x plus h and then i'm gonna
subtract a that's just the constant
times G of X there's the lower value
upper value lower value what's on the
denominator it's always H on their
denominators in it okay now remember how
when we thought about these
right we noticed that some things didn't
care about what H was you're like what
happens to this X nothing X is still X
he doesn't care about H but this guy
this does care right so it changes value
now I'm going to ask this question again
look at these two guys here a
highlighter pleat when H changes as it
gets teeny teeny tiny right what happens
to a how does age hinge like how does
this three change at the front does the
does the three change depending on what
H is it doesn't 3 is just 3 it's
completely independent right so this a
is just gonna stay as a I am so
confident it will stay a independent of
H that I can write it as a it's a factor
I can factorize the entire thing out so
I'm gonna write this a all the way out
the front
think about the G the G is not just the
number right the G is actually a
function this is function notation
I know unfortunately this is where you
just start running out of ways to write
things right if I wrote to you this
right you would rightly say that's five
times
blah-blah-blah-blah right but when you
see this hopefully your brain switches
into all this is function notation this
is not we don't mean this is multiply
this through we mean this is f is a
thing and you're putting X plus 1 into
it okay and I know it's like it's the
same notation which is a bit gross that
we have to use the same thing for both
but it does look like that but it's not
so I'm not I'm not factorizing out that
G I'm just factoring as factorizing out
the UM a so what does it leave me with
on the numerator
well hold on a second i factorized these
a's out right so what's left behind is
all the other stuff so G of X plus h and
G of X very good all over H fantastic
but have a look have a look at this
thing here what is this this by
definition is first principles for G we
store it just over here right so this is
just G - see that so what happened was
yeah you don't have a look so this is
what we're focusing on here this guy
here that by definition is this guy here
right it's just G's instead of F's just
a different label for a different
function okay what you can see is that a
which might have been three or eight pi
any number you like it ended up having
no actual effect on the process of
differentiation because you can just
factorize it out he doesn't care what H
is he can just pop right out and then
it's like as if as if the a disappeared
and then reappeared all over again
okay all right one last one and I'm not
going to go with first principles for
this one because I think your first
principles abouted a little bit you've
hadn't even had enough of first
principles for for this little chunk
okay let's think of a constant function
okay if our f of X is just a number
right like say a we could do this by
first principles we could but let's not
let's think about another way of doing
this underneath this could you draw for
me just a teeny tiny Cartesian plane
if a were a number some pick a number
for you please three through with the
first one ahead followed closely by five
all right
let's suppose a were just three what
would F of x equals three what would
that look like what kind of graph would
that be it would be a horizontal line
textbook definition a horizontal line
that goes through y equals three let's
call that three there and then here's
our horizontal line well horizontal ish
okay so there's three now remember all
of this work that we've been doing is
first principles are confi what it's
trying to calculate is hey what is your
derivative what would the original name
we gave to the derivative actually had
two words in it very close it's the it's
the it is a function it's the gradient
function right it's like hey your
gradient it changes depending on where
you are right so that's why it's a
function but this is really what I'm
calculating it's gradient that's why
this is rise over run every single time
okay now have a look at this horizontal
line for me what's the gradient the
gradient of this guy it's zero right
because it's not rising anywhere it's
not going up it's not going down so
therefore without any look my know first
principles okay I can just say F dash X
the derivative of this the gradient
function it's always zero it doesn't
have to be three it could be anywhere so
long as it's horizontal that's the
important thing
so when you've got something like this
let's put this as an example see this
guy up here you can say I can
differentiate them all separately
because of this rule the derivative of a
sum is the sum of each of the individual
to the rules when you look at this guy
right you can treat it like x squared
differentiate that and then just
multiply by three because of this
because it's just a multiple of a
function and then lastly when you do
with this guy what happens when you
differentiate this is a its own separate
thing just becomes zero right yeah so
let's just quickly rehearse this
together if this is F then F dash in
total will be first term for X to the
power three
thank you second term good because the
two
that comes out the front we'll multiply
by that three so you get 6x careful
careful
yeah this is gonna become 1 X to the
power of 0 which is just 1 and then this
guy that becomes 0 so I'll just write
that and dica okay there's our
derivative one piece at a time make
sense